time for my first guest he's an emmy
winner for his role on will and grace
he's also the insanely successful
producer of shows like grimm
hot in cleveland and hollywood game
night right now he's hosting a podcast
alongside his friends jason bateman and
will arnett
called smartless sean hayes get in here
oh my god wait are we starting this is
it
i really want you to intro on the show
just like that
oh my gosh wait wait because i didn't i
didn't speak to anybody but just kind of
it just you just appeared like
i just that's how life is i just appear
and just bless your life
it's incredible so wait is it true um
that uh so you and scott you all have
added to your family during lockdown
yes we did do you want to see this
person yes because i have a golden
doodle
oh you do yes wait i want to see
he was he was just in here
come here come here oh my god oh my gosh
he's
huge he was supposed to be a miniature
high
he was supposed to be a miniature but
he's not he's like 40 pounds
his name is henry
stop it oh my god
i woke him up and he's sleeping does he
have puppy breath
yes if puppy breath means
horrible horrible breath like mine then
yes
in the morning yeah no i it's so funny
so how big is your golden doodle going
to get is that a miniature or normal
like
normal it's normal um his parents are um
you know like um 50 to 60 pounds
well this one was supposed to be 15 to
18. lies and deception
um you're about 40. um but he is the
sweet golden doodles are so so
the reason why i went for it because we
have oh my god i used to hold him like a
baby
he's so cute yeah they're the best right
especially in quarantine because
he has to be super depressing and i only
have like
i it's not that bad i only have like
five nannies for him can you can you
can you come and see watch i just do
this can you just thank you so much
one feet hello one
one feeds one walks one naps with i love
your five nannies
um wait and then scotty will you put
will you put a um a treat
in this okay thanks did you tell me did
you tell me his name i didn't i missed
it oh his name was ricky
ricky i love it like ricky bobby or what
do we name ricky
um scott scotty named him ricky uh i
don't know why
why scotty just cuz the first name that
came to his head
i love it his new podcast is called
smart list which is awesome
um so tell me about the podcast why is
it called smart list
yeah so smartlist um jason actually
jason
it's smart list uh has three hosts it's
me jason bateman and will arnett
and no we don't talk about ozark the
whole time comes up a lot though it
comes up a lot
but um but uh we
we've been on friends for twenty some
20-ish years and
uh known each other yeah and we just
play poker
decades ago every tuesday night and so
um
we just thought why don't we we've
always wanted to work together and we've
always all three work together like
separately but never together and so
we like let's get into the podcast thing
and have an excuse to hang out every
week and talk about stuff we don't know
about because we're all idiots
and we and talk about people who know
more than us and that's why it's called
smart list because we wish we were
smarter
and so uh it's it's famous people it's
not famous people it's people from all
different walks of life like neil
degrasse tyson comes on and talks about
astrophysicists
i mean talks about i love him yeah he's
the best and uh
and uh i mean and then he can like scare
the crap out of you
yeah like i didn't realize the
definition of black hole would literally
send me into nightmares for like a month
yeah and that the earth is going to get
eaten up by black hole one day so
like cool solid merry christmas
that's awesome i love that i love that
you're just that that must be a cool
outlet especially now too we started we
were going to do we started
talking about it and organizing it in
january so
we were going to do it anyway and then
this happened so it just kind of worked
out perfectly
yeah that's awesome okay so one thing i
love about your podcast y'all's podcast
is that is it true that y'all
you you bring someone and they have no
idea who's coming and then they bring
and you have no idea who you're going to
be interviewing right so every episode
one of us acts as the host and brings on
a guess that the other two don't know
about
and so it's a surprise reveal to the
other two and the audience
although marketing will let the audience
know who's on but um
so it's cool in the moment the other two
become kind of the audience and
ask questions off the top of their head
where the other one drives the interview
oh my gosh
i love that is has it ever happened to
where one of them has been like
yay
[Laughter]
you know what for me i know nothing
about sports so i'm like i don't really
know
and then i learn about the person and
i'm fascinated so i
i love when i'm surprised when the other
two bring on somebody i don't know about
i want to be a surprise can i be a
surprise can i be your surprise one day
or do you want to
does it matter yes yes yes we i would
love that
that would be so fun they would flip out
well i kind of you said that y'all play
poker
i kind of have trouble like thinking
that you have a really good poker face
because i played games with you
like i don't have a good poker face
either i'm literally like i get a good
hand and i'm like
yeah i start laughing i'll just start
laughing i know i'm the worst if
somebody like yeah it's the worst
i know i love poker that that's fun
y'all should do that again that's fine
yeah or virtually yeah all right all
right so okay well let me try and
experiment try
i want you to try and keep a straight
face because i know that you're gonna
laugh um
while i give you something to kind of
spark your interest so i'm gonna try out
your bluff face are you ready
okay okay you have to be serious i'm
already losing it i already lost okay go
okay cool banana bread you can't hold
your face
okay new puppy see you guys
okay cool now just don't smile okay
that's really funny same person in male
and female form i couldn't do it either
okay so i i have to know about this i
heard
my producers are telling me did you
steal a sandwich
from someone especially ended up like
literally in jail
yeah i sure did um when i got to know
this story because i
that's an awesome story yeah i was i
think i was 18 years old well i was 18
years old i was my freshman year in
college
and i had no money and it's like
zero money i don't know how i even
bought a book
that was me as well yes right and so
uh we were we all went out one night and
uh
we were walking back from a party and
there was a kind of like a
not 7-11 but a 7-eleven type store and
so we walked in
and i was like oh my god i'm starving
all day and i stole a turkey sandwich
and so i walked outside with my friends
and i'm like it has tomatoes on it so we
started throwing tomatoes in the street
because we were dorks and losers and
then i'm eating it
and we're all laughing and comes up a
cop stands right in front of me and i
just see like his badge and i look up to
his face he's like
you need to come with me and i'm like
are you joking me he's like no
so i got in the cop car i had to go to
jail this kid bailed me out his name was
liam he was nicest guy didn't know him
and he gave me the hundred bucks you
didn't know him he bailed you out yeah
because it was part of like
you know it was freshman year in college
everybody's kind of meeting everybody so
i didn't know him that well
like but he was so nice and so i
borrowed 100
from my brother the next day and i paid
him back and
then cut to i don't know how many years
later i'm in los angeles
and i'm at the cafe and the guy comes up
my waiter and he goes
do you remember me i was like no he goes
emily and i bailed you out in
no way i was like wait what that's so
crazy because i hadn't seen him after he
did that he like transferred schools or
something or left
and um isn't that crazy that is correct
well what's crazier is i have a surprise
for you
liam come on in the zoom room no i'm
just kidding
could you could you imagine could you
imagine
i'm just kidding i just wanted to see
your blood face and by the way it looks
like this oh
yeah all right i'm just kidding i was
i was checking your poker face we don't
have no i i have none i have none but
if you brought liam on that would be the
best surprise ever
i've always wondered what happened to
him i know i do love running into people
i had so many odd jobs before
this or all these jobs and i do it's
funny when you
randomly run into people and it's out of
context and then you're like all the
it's almost like
certain smells bring back such nostalgic
memories or certain things it's the same
thing you're like oh my god it was a
lifetime ago
well well scent smell is the number one
uh uh a sense associated with memory yes
no i didn't know that i didn't know that
one thing we like to do in these
remote shows is get a feel for our
guests homes now we've already seen a
little bit of his media room i'm aware
um but i thought we could see a little
more so i love games he loves games i
love winning he might
probably lose um might probably that's
good um
so sean has agreed to join me in a
friendly competition
it's time to play zoom around the room
all right it's simple parents you can
even play this at home with your kids i
know that you're running out of the
circus thing of trying to entertain your
kids me too
um so here's how it's done we'll be
given a random word or phrase by my
executive producer alex
then we each run and find an object to
match that word
and whoever gets back to their camera
first with the item
gets the point remember i just turned 50
remember registering 50.
well remember i might have just moved
out of this house so i don't know what's
here
but i do have my running shoes on so
good
it looks like a cute dress but really
i'm sporting pants and my working girl
yeah there you go all right well don't
slip those might be slippery um
okay alex go
i was sitting in it i was sitting here
you are sitting in a chair you win you
win
i had a guitar i was right behind i'm
i'm just happy i had something wooden in
here
um this is a card that i've never played
actually this one isn't mine so
yes okay i'm gonna put this back up hold
on
so it's still pretty in the set here we
go
oh god look at your doggy i love him oh
henry is the best
he literally is the greatest dog i
lucked out um
okay what's the next word shawn gets
that one adorable
adorable i'm just gonna sit here
henry
hi scott okay i think i would have
grabbed i would have grabbed my doggy
but he's sleeping
hi um i like that what's up man i
literally just did this
you're welcome adorable um i don't think
i won that one either i don't know who's
gonna get that point
okay wait do another word for us alex
disgusting
okay disgusting
is that she ever coming back
should be great i found something
plunger oh dog
i'm gonna put it backwards both had to
do with poo
okay i bet you get that point you had
dog poop that was
awesome okay one more okay here we go
okay
something that your mom gave you oh my
gosh
mine's funnier if it's revealed okay
wait that took a minute because
this is hard for me okay what's yours
[Applause]
what is that it's a slide whistle
i've never heard or seen that you never
heard the song groove is in the heart
is that what it is yeah never knew
look at that learn something every day i
did not your mom gave you that
i i don't know i think so i am
i i don't have i literally just moved so
all i mean obviously i took the things
my mother would have given me
but she did give me a love of puzzles
and i've been puzzled
well yours is sweeter okay well yours is
cooler
i didn't even know that existed so i was
like wow you need to put it in a song
i know i will now i will steal that i
will rip that from grimace in the heart
um i think you kicked my butt yeah no
i had no chance in hell that's awesome
hey thank you so much
yes i adore you and i'm so great to hang
with you
oh you two and hey congratulations on
ricky he's
adorable golden noodles are the best
dogs you're gonna love him
i'm so excited thanks honey all right
well it's always great to see you sean i
love you so much um you can find sean's
new
podcast smart list wherever you listen
to your podcast
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going